we begin with this the White House faces
a deadline today to decide whether to
impose new tariffs on all Mexican
imports a third day of intense
negotiations between US and Mexican
officials will try to stop those tariffs
from taking effect on Monday president
Trump is threatening tariffs to get
Mexico's government to do more to stop
illegal immigration Mexico seems to be
taking a tougher stance offering to use
troops to block migrants along its
southern border we just yang is at the
White House
weed your time is running out on these
tariffs and in fact Mexico I was reading
this morning has already tripled
deportations in the past three or four
months so what solution will actually
satisfy the president a good morning
Tony you know Mexico is scrambling to
figure that out because you're right
they've already proposed a variety of
ways to control illegal migration but so
far the administration is not satisfied
plus a White House official said
President Trump has not spoken directly
with his Mexican counterparts and they
are the only two people who can sign off
on a deal I said we're gonna put tariffs
on because we want you to help us with
because they won't pass any legislation
in Congress in a Fox News interview that
aired late last night President Trump
defended his plan to impose tariffs on
all Mexican imports confident they will
force Mexico to cut off the flow of
Central Americans at the southern border
that's despite criticism from those
within his own party who say American
consumers will suffer tariffs are a
beautiful thing it's a beautiful word if
you know how to use them properly
Republicans should love what I'm doing
this week hundreds of Mexican law
enforcement officers blocked about a
thousand migrants at the Mexico
Guatemala border CBS News has learned
Mexico offered to deploy 6,000 troops
there but the White House said that was
not enough Mexico then agreed to change
its asylum policy to force migrants to
apply for refuge in Mexico if they have
entered the country instead of crossing
over to do it in the u.s. something
Mexico has long resisted both sides said
they have made progress but not enough
to reach an agreement I go into the room
with the Mexicans I'm asking them for
every
thing and by the way if they don't do it
I'm putting the tariffs on we're gonna
make a fortune
Oh President Trump is scheduled to
return back here to the White House
later today after spending the week in
Europe and that could expedite the
deal-making process as the deadline
looms but if the tariffs do kick in the
president is considering declaring a new
national emergency to justify the
measure Dina all right we dragged in
just the beginning it looks like thank
you very much